[Musique]
bonsoir à tous le 7-8 journal de tv
soixante dix huit pour faire le tour de
l'actualité locale et régionale
bienvenue dans cette édition du mercredi
12 juin voici les titres
cette technologie est au service des
apiculteurs une start-up des yvelines a
développé une ruche connectée elle
permet de surveiller la santé des
abeilles insectes pollinisateurs ô
combien important pour la biodiversité
elles sont revenus du vietnam faux mais
cinq étudiantes de versailles sont
partis pendant presque un mois dans la
nation asiatique une mission humanitaire
menée dans un orphelinat du sud du pays
adèle inès mélodies clémence et marion
seront en plateau pour témoigner et puis
la baguette la meilleure baguette de
tradition des yvelines 2019 et de chatou
elle est produite par une boulangerie et
familiale a été récompensé lors du 10e
concours organisé par la chambre de
métiers et d'artisanat du département et
puis nous parlerons également d'une
soirée caritative au programme ce samedi
c'est au prisme à elancourt il est
disponible depuis aujourd'hui aux
guichets des gares franciliennes
ile-de-france mobilité danse un nouveau
pass le navigo isi pour 2 euros
cette carte anonyme permet de charger
des tickets dématérialisée elle est
destinée surtout aux touristes aux
usagers occasionnels des transports en
commun à le navigo easy doit remplacer
d'ici 2021 l'ensemble des tickets en
carton 500 millions de ces billets sont
utilisés chaque année
avantage financier est aussi écologique
ces tickets met près d'un an à se
dégrader
cette initiative étonnante justement un
rapport avec l'environnement menée par
une jeune entreprise yvelinoise elle
s'est associée à une start up et à
l'opérateur orange pour connecter et les
ruches une vingtaine est en cours
d'équipement dans le département le but
le but c'est de mieux connaître l la vie
et la santé des abeilles afin de mieux
de mieux les protéger si mélanie poker
un simple boîtier de quelques
centimètres carrés un capteur qui prend
place au coeur d'une ruche pour
comprendre la vie et les besoins des
cent cinquante mille abeilles de ce
rucher à l'initiative melli police une
toute jeune entreprise yvelinoise on va
relever surtout les gros maîtrise donc
me dit et on va dire ambiante et puis la
température à travers ses dimensions va
être capable de mesurer la santé des
seins et l'activité de l'eso l'activité
de l'essaim à certaines périodes peut
nous permettre de nous alerter en cas
d'anomalie puisque on a on va dire les
standards et en comparaison à ses
standards on sera capable de dire ok ce
n'est pas normal aujourd'hui d'avoir ce
taux d'humidité
meli police est en train d'équiper 18
ruche une installation possible grâce à
orange l'opérateur les a notamment mis
en relation avec la start up au stabi ça
permet effectivement de faire entrer une
vieille profession dans dans l'ère du
21e siècle avec la connexion c'est pas
le tout comme dans les yvelines de
rendre plus de 400 mille logements
raccordables on en prend trois de plus
qui sont les logements déjà guèye c'est
un freak siens qui est humain qui est
financée effectivement comme dans le
cadre de cette action puisque c'est nous
qui prenons en charge par exemple
acquisition de des capteurs mais il est
également en biologie ce cri quand un
métier en thaïlande expertise pour tout
ce qui est un trait au numérique
le concept est aujourd'hui en études sur
deux communes chesnais rocancourt et
chavenay melli police espère le
développer sur le courant de l'année
2020 en france près de 30% des colonies
disparaissent chaque année
les abeilles représente 35% de la
production alimentaire mondiale dans
l'actualité en bref la mauvaise nouvelle
pour les salariés de blizzard d'aversa
et la filiale européenne de ce géant du
jeu vidéo entend se séparer de 134 de
ses salariés ils devraient être
licenciés dans les prochaines semaines l
e groupe adopté hier un plan de
sauvegarde de l'emploi qui prévoit la
réduction d'un tiers de ses effectifs il
sera soumis à la validation de la
direccte est de leur côté les syndicats
ont émis un avis négatif sur ce pse il
dénonce à des licenciements effectués
dans un contexte favorable pour blizzard
dans février la société annonçait un
bénéfice record de presque 1,9 milliard
d'euros
après la villa viardot à bougival un
deuxième monument
yvelinois sera soutenue par le loto du
patrimoine c'est l'orangerie du château
edano cours à gargenville un bâtiment
datant du xviiie siècle fréquenté
notamment par napoléon 1er est apprécié
pour ses plafonds peints de feuillage
est mais le lieu est en ruine car à
l'abandon depuis plusieurs années le
coût total de la réhabilitation est
estimé à 1,5 million d'euros sept ans de
travaux au moins sont nécessaires pour
redonner à l'orangerie une seconde
jeunesse
elles sont cinq autour de la table avec
moi cinq étudiantes en deuxième année à
d'assistant de service social à
versailles bonsoir à vous marion
clairement synes adèle et mélodie je me
contentais des prénoms
alors vous êtes rentré fin mai d'une
mission humanitaire dans le sud du viêt
du vietnam
on vous étés vous étiez venu sur ce
plateau en octobre dernier pour
présenter cette mission ce projet déjà
si vous deviez dresser un premier bilan
de cette expérience
adel alors on en tire un bilan plutôt
positif parce qu'on a réussi à mettre en
place une bonne partie de nos missions
en plus de ça nous avons pu faire un
état des lieux de la population de
l'orphelinat des enduits handicap qui se
trouvaient dans leur femina et nous
sommes très contentes car l'année
prochaine un groupe d'étudiants de notre
classe fin de notre école prend le
relais et va partir dans deux autres
orphelinat au vietnam
la même association en tout cas quelque
chose a été lancé ça pourra suivre dans
les prochaines années alors vous êtes
rendus dans un orphelinat du sud du pays
de ce pays le vietnam qui se situent en
asie du sud est
on rappelle aux téléspectateurs pour
ceux qui n'avaient pas vu la première
interview pourquoi vous étiez partis sur
place pour pour rappel en fait on était
parti en place c'était une demande de
l'orphelinat de van thao de faire partir
un groupe d'étudiants pour la première
fois en plus assistants de service
social dans le but en fait qu'on puisse
auprès des enfants mener des actions de
sensibilisation par rapport à l'hygiène
la sexualité et l'insertion
professionnelle donc au niveau de la
sexualité on a pu s'appuyer sur une
association qui s'appelle alliance anti
trafic qui à 25 ans une association
française qui on a travaillé en
partenariat avec lui en fait pour
pouvoir mener nos actions sur place
auprès des enfants
et concernant l'insertion
professionnelle on a eu la chance de
pouvoir passer une journée entière à hô
chi minh avec les plus grands de
l'orphelinat et de pouvoir visiter une
des structures de l'association help it
for you donc c'est une association et
également française
qui aide les jeunes en fait dans à les
insérer dans la vie professionnelle par
des formations ou bien des stages on va
revenir sur le programme sur place que
vous avez effectués sur place
c'est une mission humanitaire qui a été
menée avec l'association e pvn ses
enfants ce partenariat vietnam quelle
est cette association et comment vous at
elle accompagner dans ce projet cela
fait donc l'association enfin ce
partenariat vietnam
elle a été créée il ya onze ans elle a
pour but d'améliorer les conditions de
vie d'éducation et de santé des enfants
du vietnam et elle compte aujourd'hui on
peu près 500 adhérents et elle est
composée uniquement de bénévoles donc
l'association il nous a aidés en fait
dans la logique toute la logistique du
projet donc c'est madame cavaliers la
présidente de l'association qui a géré
vraiment la logistique donc au niveau de
nos visages retrouvée orpheline accès
mais qui était vu la dernière fois sur
ce plateau
exactement et sur place elle nous a
aidés en étant toujours disponible en
nous écoutant pour organiser nos
ateliers sur l'ajustement quel a été le
programme mélodies alors il faut
rappeler déjà que en fait on était à
l'orphelinat de 23 ans ainsi qu'à la
maison social de longueuil est donc
cette maison social de longueuil
c'est une maison en fait qui accueille
des enfants de la rue et des enfants en
situation de handicap pour leur donner
un niveau d'instruction est donc dans
ces deux structures on a pu mener des
ateliers de prévention et de
sensibilisation pour à travers des jeux
dédiés
voilà le programme sur place et est ce
que vous diriez que cette aventure vous
a marqué professionnellement peut être
humainement aussi mais bon ça ne peut
que nos marques et professionnellement
et humainement c'est vrai que cela
confirme pour certains d'entre nous
l'intérêt de travailler avec un certain
public dans notre profession par exemple
travaillé dans le champ de l'enfance ou
bien dans le champ du handicap
et puis cela nous a permis d'élargir
notre esprit à travers de nouveaux
horizons et c'est un élément qui est
plutôt important dans le travail social
aujourd'hui à quoi ça va vous servir du
coup cette expérience que ça vous vous
servir dans votre cursus votre vie
personnelle peut-être bien sûr que ça ne
sert dans notre vie personnelle parce
que et dans notre vie professionnelle
également car ça nous permet de
d'apprendre à nous organiser d'apprendre
à prioriser aussi et de vivre en
collectivité
chose très importante également et puis
ça nous permet également de prendre du
recul par rapport aux choses auxquels on
peut être confrontés dans notre
profession de relativiser de gérer en
plus pardon le sentiment de frustration
et puis de se confronter à la barrière
de la langue une dernière question
peut-être qu'on va donner la parole
aussi à vous tout va on va commencer
avec vous mélodie est ce que ça vous a
donné envie de vous engager davantage
dans l'humanitaire ce genre de mission
je pense que chacun d'entre nous à son
avis sur la question après oui
professionnellement parlant extrait
serait bien de partir avec d'autres
associations telles que père et anne
pour mener à bien des actions comme
celle là mais comme il nous reste un
petit peu de temps à des lois fait un
petit tour de table est ce que vous
aussi ça vous a donné davantage envie de
vous engager à m'a donné envie surtout
aussi de suivre d'autres groupes les
prochains groupes qui vont pouvoir
partir au vietnam dont six dans notre
futur professionnel de travailler avec
des associations telle confiance
partenariat vietnam
marion j'ai beaucoup aimé aussi
découvrir une nouvelle culture donc
j'aimerais bien mais effectivement
repartir je peux être en mission
humanitaire dans un futur proche pour
boucler mon je rejoins ma rien sur ce
point là et puis pourquoi pas même
continuer en tant que bénévole dans
l'association font ce partenariat
vietnam grand projet d'accord et on
termine avec vous ce tournoi a été une
expérience très forte déjà a donc
forcément j'ai envie de recommencer
alors en orphelinat ou ailleurs mais en
tout cas ça donne envie de repartir pour
ce genre d'aventuré bon je vous souhaite
en tout cas bravo enfin on vous dit
bravo
et on pourra peut-être recevoir les
prochaines étudiante les prochaines
étudiante les prochains étudiants qui
partiront sur cette mission au vietnam
merci à vous mélodies inez clémence
marion et adel pour être passé sur ce
plateau
oui à les ide celle entre 9 et souvent
les remerciements pour l'entreprise
normand de la ville de versailles
le département des yvelines c'est que
tous les donateurs qui nous ont permis
de réussir ce projet le message est
passé merci encore à vous avant de
parler solidarité encore pause dans ce
journal qui voudraient donnera sûrement
fin la baguette de tradition était à
l'honneur hier à versailles et des prix
ont été décernés aux meilleurs
boulangers yvelinois dans le cadre du
10e concours organisé par la chambre de
métiers et de l'artisanat
cette année c'est un
établissement familial situé à chatou
qui a remporté tous les suffrages au
rayon des patries jacques de dixmude de
la farine de l'eau de la levure du sel
et vous obtenez une baguette tradition
celle ci est un peu particulière puisque
c'est la meilleure des yvelines celui
qui l'a façonné c'est martial guégan un
profil atypique puisqu'il détient une
licence de mathématiques un master en
management
cela fait seulement cinq ans qu'ils
travaillent dans cette entreprise
familiale à chatou à l'école primaire
les mercredis après midi je les passais
dans le
dans le fournil à faire des gâteaux ou
du pain
voilà mes jeux j'avais envie de faire
autre chose à la basse et plus
j'avançais plus
l'envy d'entreprise prônait et j'avais
cet appel vers ce savoir faire et ce que
je connais depuis tout petit 120
apprentis employés et chefs
d'entreprises ont participé à ce
concours
depuis dix ans les objectifs n'ont pas
changé promouvoir la baguette de
tradition française et l'artisanat
il ya nos cinq sens qu'ils sont en éveil
1 je veux dire quand vous passez devant
la boulangerie vous avez basse et l
odorat évidemment avec les bonnes et
plus du bon pains chauds vous avez donc
le visuel
quand on la découpe on doit avoir ce
qu'on appelle une mie alvéolé donc
irrégulière et sauvage
il y a quatre ans le jeune boulanger
avait déjà remporté le prix du meilleur
croissant des yvelines cette année pour
la baguette tradition c'est sa recette
secrète qui a sans doute fait toute la
différence
j'ai utilisé en fait une recette d'une
pré fermentation qui s'appelle sur
pouliches c'est une partie de la pâte
qu'on fait fermenter 48 heures à
l'avancé pour l'ajouter dans la pâte au
dernier moment pour faire le camp et ça
ça permet de donner plus de goût
l'année prochaine sa baguette tradition
représentera les yvelines au concours
national
d'anciennes gloires du paris saint
germain et des personnalités réunis pour
la bonne cause un match de gala s'est
déroulé au parc des sports de
feucherolles il ya quelques jours au
profit de l'association enfants de la
terre elle a été créée notamment paris
yannick noah pour accompagner les
enfants hospitalisés en difficultés
sociales et économiques sur la pelouse
laurent fournier habib beye vincent
guérin ou encore alain roche 6000 euros
ont pu être récoltés à l'occasion de
cette rencontre un événement qui
comprenait également aidé tournoi de
football à 5 et qui se déroulait dans
une ambiance bonne enfant vous allez le
voir avec ses interviews collectées par
michael humide euros sur la bonne
franquette on va se faire charrier par
les joueurs de foot ils vont nous
ridiculiser
nous on va leur mettre des coups on est
presque en forme donc tu vas bien est-ce
conforme c'est-à-dire presque ça siffle
un peu maintenant à anne aux âges mais
un spoiler on est là pour le pour le
plaisir et pour pour les gens aussi au
tour donc c'est toujours bien de
retrouver les vieux amis les nouveaux
amis dans un en plus j'habite ici dans
cette ville donc ça va ça fait plaisir
et puis en plus est pour une belle
association donc les enfants de la terre
et on sait que c'est important d'être
présent
on m'a dit que c'était pour une
association les enfants de la terre 6
mois dans la compétition un peu
difficilement j'ai 20 ans d'arrêt mais
je veux dire gourcuff l'a fait pourquoi
pas moi c'est également un événement
caritatif pas sur les terrains mais sur
scène cette fois ci la compagnie alegria
proposent tous en scène une comédie
musicale jouée ce samedi au prisme
elancourt c'est à 20h30 et c'est une
soirée qui est au profit des oeuvres du
lion's-club d'elancourt alors pour en
parler en plateau sur cette table autour
de cette table plusieurs invités
clotilde longeons bonsoir présidente de
la compagnie alegria lucien calixte
bonsoir bonsoir directeur artistique de
cette compagnie et vous mettez en scène
donc tous en scène sur ma droite nous
avons christophe goran bon soir il est
membre du lions club et l'encours à quoi
l'ina et vous êtes en charge plus
particulièrement de la communication et
des reliques provençal bonsoir pension
résidente du lion's-club élan pour aqua
linas t'avoue que je donne la parole en
premier
rappelez nous ce qu'est le lion ce club
quelles sont les missions du lot ce club
alors l'alliance club d'elancourt equal
et n'a été créé il ya quatre ans et nous
organisons plusieurs manifestations
humanitaire et humaniste toujours au
profit des élans courtois mais aussi du
bien pour tout le monde il ya toujours
cet onglet humanitaire caritatif
voilà alors nous on agit pour la lecture
on agit pour l'autisme
on fait du tournoi de tennis des
concerts des lotos et comme ce soir
alegria pour l'autisme cette fois mais
on va on va présenter dans quelques
instants le programme de la soirée
déjà pourquoi l'organiser cette soirée
quels sont les objectifs
alors le
l'objectif c'est de financer un chien de
médiation pour un enfant autiste
le lionceau billancourt à condom a fait
d'un projet phare le financement de deux
chiens pour des enfants
on a un local de l'année dernière
financer un chien pour un enfant qui
s'appelle oscars qui est atteint du
syndrome de gilles de la tourette et
j'en ai un peu l'émotion d'en parler
parce que j'ai les images qui me
reviennent c'est c'est très important de
de permettre à ces enfants de mieux
vivre leur maladie et oscar le vit mieux
depuis depuis quelques temps sa famille
le vit mieux et point de vue du club
nous on se rende compte que grâce à nous
les des personnes vivent mieux le
quotidien quand on est atteint d un
chiot médiation on imagine de par le
profil du chien le nombre d'années de
formation j'imagine c'est c'est un chien
qui coûte cher aujourd'hui c'est un
chien c'est un chien finances et qui
coûte entre 10 et 15 mille euros tout
dépend le le niveau de formation par
exemple pour un chien pour un enfant
handicapé pour des handicaps lourds sont
va tourner aux attentes 15000 euros pour
pour oscar le chat qui s'appelle neo
on est sur un budget de dix mille euros
vont un peu plus c'est une dresseuse qui
est actuellement en train toujours de
dresser son chien ça fait deux ans
qu'elle le fait actuellement le budget
il a dix mille mais il ya encore des
choses à financer par la suite donc oui
du côté de la compagnie alegria pourquoi
s'associer à ce type d'événement alors
nous sommes très touchés par par
l'objectif de vos actions depuis notre
notre premier spectacle c'est notre
septième spectacle nous fêtons notre
dixième anniversaire nous avons toujours
joué en faveur d'oeuvres qui viennent
d'oeuvre en faveur d'enfants en faveur
de recherche médicale et nous avons joué
pour une quinzaine d'oeuvres déjà et
quand vous avez parlé de 2,7 de ce
projet on était très enthousiaste c'est
notre septième spectacle
notre association qui s'appelle alegria
écoles pour la présenter cette
association
oui enfin quel type de quel type de
spectacle vous développez justement
alors se sont aidés des spectacles de
très joyeux très très vivant alegria on
en a choisi ce nom parce que comme
alegria commeinhes et grèce a comme
accueillant des deux ailes comme l'amour
de la vie de l'amour de la scène nous
sommes une quarantaine de deux chanteurs
danseurs comédiens autour de notre
directeur artistique lucien calixte et
nous avons aussi à chaque fois c'est une
aventure humaine une aventure artistique
on est tous réunis autour d'une passion
c'est la passion de la scène la question
du spectacle les amateurs mais on fait
ça on joue avec tout notre coeur est
avec tout notre enthousiasme et notre
notre énergie
et si on faisait un peu partout dans le
département en ile de france
oui alors en ile-de-france et
dans le département en a joué depuis
plusieurs années aux montants ciel on a
beaucoup de chance d'avoir la confiance
du monde entier et puis on a joué aussi
avec lan pham l'association des familles
de militaires à polytechnique
on a joué aux chaînes et à la grande
scène du chesnay et puis on a pu jouer
aussi à paris à la scène à l'espace
cardin et puis aussi aux docks de paris
donc on a eu la chance d'avoir deux très
belles scènes parce que nous sommes 40
sur scène et donc il faut de la place et
vous mettez en scène justement tous en
scène
le pitch du spectacle vous nous emmenez
à broadway c'est ça avec cette salle
c'est un mashup de deux comédies
musicales tous en scène et chante on sur
le puits singing ballerines c'est la
rencontre d'un artiste qui était très
connu qui est en perte de vitesse avec
une jeune artiste qui elle n'est encore
rien fait et qui croit tout savoir et
donc ces deux là se retrouvent dans un
projet
et c'est un prétexte comme dans toutes
les comédies musicales des années 40 50
c'est un prétexte à faire des gros
tableau avec des plaines costume de la
joie de la bonne humeur et cette troupe
l'a d'ailleurs fait me me donne
exactement ce que ce que j'espère voir
si ça c'est tout c'est de cet
enthousiasme cette vraiment explosif où
et comment voulez venir on s'aime comme
on voulait réfléchir justement vous êtes
inspiré vous le dites je comédie
musicale je suis obligé les membres et
écrire les dialogues de récrire toutes
les histoires puisque à chaque fois
c'est ce sont des mélanges
donc je réécris tout ça est en fonction
aussi des artistes qui sont là
puisqu'ils sont amateurs autant
exploiter vraiment ce qu'ils sont et
arriver à tirer du le meilleur d'eux
même si on en revient du coup aux
objectifs de la soirée les ingrédients
de la réussite pour que cette fois il
justement une soirée réussie
quels sont ils ces ingrédients font
danser chanter avec nous avec eux et
puis voilà et tous les bénéfices seront
reversés pour ce chien de médiation et
on rappelle peut-être toute l'importance
du chien de médiation pourquoi est il
intéressant justement pour pour l'enfant
autiste justement un le chien de
médiation il permet en fait à la dans le
cas qu'on connaît avec oscar à ce
qu'oscar vivent avec le chien
indépendamment de ses parents c'est à
dire que ça a permis aussi d'une grosse
bouffée d'oxygène à ses parents et du
coup
le on est sûr de pas si vous connaissez
le terme de calinothérapie ça se
pratique avec les chevaux et c'est le un
peu le même principe en fait avec les
chiens et du coup la hausse car il a
fait des progrès énormes depuis que de
tous qu'il est présent avec aux côtés de
donner aux fans et aux parents et aux
présents que de dos car oscar maintenant
va à l'école tout seul accompagné de son
chien
quelque chose qui ne faisait pas il ya
un an de ça et donc on vous encourage à
venir pour aider à financer ce genre
d'initiatives pour une soirée aussi
festive qui se déroule donc je le
rappelle ce samedi au prisme d'elancourt
tous en scène un spectacle au profit des
oeuvres du lion's-club d'elancourt 7 à
20 heures 30 et le tarif c'est 18 euros
10 euros pour les moins de 10 ans et ça
et la billetterie est ouverte sur pour
les moins de 12 ans la billetterie est
ouverte sur le site du lion's-club
d'elancourt qui s'affiche à l'écran
merci à bout 4 d'être passé sur ce tabou
la direction a plaisir à présent où
depuis 16 ans la ville organise le
festival escales d'ailleurs un rendez
vous culturel cosmopolite pour rendre
hommage à cet aspect de la commune
marylène iapichino et michael et demi
d'euros
de la musique et de la danse libanaise
dans la cour des commandes du parc du
château de plaisir et ce qu'elle
d'ailleurs concert sa recette gagnante
un festival on se moque onyx monter la
tension et vallet et pour les peuples
française on voulait vraiment
accompagner les familles et surtout le
mélange au public nous avons sur plaisir
c'est pour ça que vous entendez des
musiques aussi variés et puis alors y
est surtout d accueil pour les enfants
avec des jeux et puis il ya de la danse
et de la musique
donc tout ça pour dire que on a visé
particulièrement le mélange les
quartiers et les familles des familles
qui sont nombreux à venir chaque année
ils sont entre 8 et 12 mine à découvrir
des jeux et spectacles originaux
c est des moments qu'ils soient magie
des moments merveilleux aulas prend
d'autres cultures et d'autres d'autres
traditions et donc c'est très important
de le faire
l'occasion d'observer des progrès de sa
progéniture le conservatoire de plaisir
participent aux festivités avec
notamment la section danse ou si je la
vois correctement jeu n'ont pas
l'occasion de venir parce que féfé
agréable on peut manger on peut jouer
côtoyer des gens et fait vachement
conviviale les différentes scènes ont
accueilli des spectacles jusque dans la
nuit un grand moment de partage culturel
et de voyages allez on referme ce
journal au cinéma comme tous les
mercredis notre petit tour dans les
salles du territoire ce soir
présentation de la programmation des
yeux d'elsa c'est à saint cyr l'école et
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
au cinéma les yeux d'elsa en cette fin
d'année scolaire
on va essayer de faire se rassembler les
familles autour du cinéma et dans cette
salle de cinéma avec le festival les
yeux pleins d'étoilés sa neuvième
édition et on souhaite que les gens
viennent passer des bons moments en
famille avec leurs enfants entre
grands-parents et petits-enfants dans
cette salle de cinéma pour partager et
construire des souvenirs ensemble
alors on va avoir une soirée ciné
frisson qui s'adresse plus évidemment
aux adolescents et aux gens qui aiment
le cinéma d'horreur avec puff et prince
des ténèbres mais on va aussi avoir du
cinéma de patrimoine avec cyrano de
bergerac
on va aussi avoir des films des vraies
comédies comme le retour du héros de
laurent tirard avec dujardin et mélanie
thierry qu'on a passés ont déjà cette
année mais qui est tellement drôle qu'on
avait envie de leur montrer le roi et
l'oiseau grand film de cinéma
d'animation français un mix ce film
qu'on vous invite à venir découvrir ou
redécouvrir une salle de cinéma c'est
toujours une expérience formidable
et puis
on va rediffuser des films qui ont été
passés dans le cadre de école et cinéma
dans le département cette année
le garçon est le monde et la petite
vendeuse de soleil un film sénégalais
deux petites merveilles que les enfants
dans les écoles ont découvert cette
année et qu'on invite à venir découvrir
avec leur famille avec leurs parents à
faire découvrir ce film
et puis pour finir le dimanche 30 juin
on fera une journée autour
le samedi 29 juin et le dimanche 30 juin
on fera deux journées autour du cinéma
avec des films comme capitaine morten
rênes d'un été où on fera des ateliers
d'accompagnement autour de ses films et
puis le dimanche 30 juin au matin à 10h
un ciné conte pour les plus petits pour
partager en famille à un moment original
de cinéma et de spectacles vivants alors
j'espère vous retrouver le plus nombreux
possible à partir du 21 juin
pour le ciné frisson et jusqu'au 30 juin
pour cette journée d'animation au cinéma
les et dalsa c'est la fin de ce journal
dans un instant nouveau numéro du 7-8
débats a présenté par aurélie rose
langue étrangère sommes nous vraiment
mauvais c'est la question posée ce soir
quant à moi je vous retrouve dès demain
pour une nouvelle édition belle soirée
sur tv 78
[Musique]